peter king from nbc sports joins us
right now their nfl insider and
peter thank you so much for taking the
time to call in today
sure susie how are you i'm great i'm
great i'm
better than they are in seattle i think
i'd love to pick your brain on what you
think is happening
up there in seattle with the russell
wilson saga
well i think for a long time um
and seattle uh people
are not uh exclusive to this
for a long time uh quarterbacks
and most players in the nfl haven't
really had a lot of authority
inside the organization even after they
uh have been there and played very well
like russell wilson has started every
game since
he was drafted in 2012 and he's a
regular
uh playoff producer uh for seattle
been to two super bowls um and i think
russell wilson
kind of looks around the league he sees
the authority and the
uh how much impact tom brady has
on the decision-making process in tampa
he
hears and reads the stories about
patrick mahomes coming in and saying hey
andy why can't we do this
and then andy puts andy reid puts it in
the playbook
so i think he wants to have
some of that level of um
you know participation in the process
and
you know john schneider is sort of a uh
you know from the ron wolfe school
i'll pick the players the coaches will
coach him and the players will play
and i'm not saying that uh john
schneider is not going to
listen to russell wilson because i think
he would listen to russell wilson but
i think particularly now when it comes
to the coaching
side of it i think russell wilson wants
more input it's very clear that he wants
more input on what is done
and uh we'll see where it goes but
uh it's not headed down a good path
right now would you predict at this
point
i'm just curious do you think he stays
there for the what i was saying before
in the first segment is pete carroll's a
70 year old coach he's not going to want
to be in a rebuilding process right now
well you know it's kind of interesting
pete carroll does turn seventy in
september
uh he's going to be playing with a 32
year old quarterback
and you have to ask yourself this
question
i mean because it sounds like if we
continue going down this road and it
continues to be this way
that at some point russell wilson is
going to turn into desean watson
like i'm not playing here anymore and so
i think if that happens seattle's gonna
have to make a decision
uh do they want to i mean and they'll
make it long before
they get to this point who are they
going to side with do they want to side
with
keeping pete carroll and starting all
over at the quarterback position
and susie as you know the quarterback is
an absolute total crapshoot in the nfl
and russell wilson was the 75th pick in
the draft
and in 2012 well in 2016
the first pick in the draft is gone
you know you know jared goff
and and so that's why it is so
you have no idea who's gonna make it who
isn't going to make it so
i guess i would just say that my gut
feeling is
that they're going to coexist this year
and then if it doesn't get any better
this year
that maybe they have their armageddon
moment after this season but
i'm not saying it can't happen before
this year either
susie schuster peter king here on the
rich eisen show can we delve a little
bit deeper into
out of curiosity his choice of teams
bears saints cowboys raiders how do you
make sense of that i mean it makes more
sense
and you know depending on how drew brees
wants to
look at this season saints
cowboys we could see that raiders bears
what do you think peter
the saints make all the sense in the
world because who wouldn't
if you're a quarterback who wouldn't
want to play for sean payton
susie two years ago uh
in november of what what would have been
19
i forget no it would have been november
of 18
i sat in the uh in the
quarterback or in the uh offensive
meeting room
saturday night before a philadelphia new
orleans game
and i watched as sean payton
and drew brees and the offensive staff
sat there and they went over
every play in the offensive game plan
brees saying i like this i don't like
this i like this
and it's basically called the black dot
meeting
because in that meeting drew brees
uh sean payton puts a black dot next to
the plays that brees
really likes and i think the night i was
there
there was 40 some odd place let's say 43
45 something like that
that peyton put the black dot next to
him and we're walking out of the meeting
and i asked sean i said how many of
those plays do you think you'll call
tomorrow
and he said i hope everyone and so
you know i get a fee i get the feeling
that russell wilson does not have
that relationship with his coaching
staff so who wouldn't want
a relationship with your head coach
where the head coach says
what do you want to run tomorrow and you
tell them and then basically the next
day
he calls those plays so i think that
is something that russell wilson would
love to have as would
almost every quarterback but you know
the one
outlier in that in that list really
seems like the bears
because i mean look
how much are you going to have to trade
to get russell wilson susie they got the
20th pick in the draft i mean
that's certainly not as valuable as say
the jets at
two or miami at three that's why
that one really stuck out to me who who
are they going to
they don't have a quarterback to trade
to seattle unless they could get seattle
and take nick foles
now and that's not impossible but that
certainly doesn't have the value
he's not going to be your long-term
quarterback that's the only one that
really stuck out and
and was a little bit quizzical to me
the deshaun watson difference of course
being that
number one he's 25 he hasn't gone he
hasn't he hasn't won a super bowl
russell wilson you just think it's been
so long
they have won a super bowl they've been
back i'm curious about the difference
and we'll segue into the into the
deshaun watson side after this but
i i get it i think that it's hard for
russell wilson
at his age and with his stature he sees
these younger kids being listened to
more than he is
and it could be something as simple as
that it's him just putting his foot down
saying i want to be heard
yeah i mean look i think this is
multi-layered
i think this has to do with the fact
that
what is he you know he gets man of the
year this year
but which is great and he's wanted to
win man of the year for some time
but although he won man of the year
he goes and sits in roger goodell's box
at the super bowl and he looks miserable
because he's watching tom brady at age
43
have exactly what he wants tom brady
having a say with byron leftwich and
bruce arians
in everything that they do tom brady
uh parachuting into a team with
tremendous offensive talent and
russell wilson has got to be watching
that game with a little sense of envy
saying you know what if i were in tom
brady's shoes
i would have won the super bowl this
year and i'm sure a lot of quarterbacks
could say that but you know what russell
wilson is probably right he could have
won the super bowl
with that surrounding supporting cast
this year
but i and i think he just has a little
bit of envy when he looks at a lot of
quarterback situations around the league
and sees things that he doesn't have
let's move on to deshaun watson
is this the strangest situation that
you've seen in a trade
in a trade demand so soon after a
contract is negotiated and signed
for a 25 year old kid to say i'm not
playing back if you give us some
perspective
have you ever seen something so strange
i really haven't and you know
in the first four months of his new
contract
uh deshaun watson made 28.1 million
dollars which
you know dwarfs the money he made uh
earlier you know in the first uh four
years of his career
nearly four years of his career so
um you know it is weird
it's very strange and i don't think five
years ago
that uh i don't think five
well i shouldn't say this i'm not sure
that five years ago
that a quarterback who had been he
felt like he had been wronged by the
owner of his team
i'm not sure five years ago a
quarterback is going to say that's it
i'm never playing for this team
again but quarterbacks are gaining
the power in the nfl you saw tom brady
pick up and go where he wanted to go
matthew stafford told the lions i want
out the lions complied
carson wentz i want out the eagles
complied
um and we'll see if houston complies
the difference is that there is never
been in nfl history
who is in his prime at such a young age
at age 25 a top five quarterback in the
nfl
traded it just has never happened now
people might say well wait a minute
steve young was
25 when he was traded by tampa to san
francisco
but that was a totally different thing
steve young had been
brutalized in the usfl uh with the los
angeles express
and then he went to the worst team in
the nfl tampa bay
and got the crap beat out of him for a
year plus
and so you know he wasn't what deshawn
watson is right now
watson's coming off one of the best
years in the nfl for a quarterback in
2020
so that's why this is so different
uh from anything i think most of us if
not all of us have ever seen
and no team wants to be the team that
goes forward with that trade and sees
him win
right away somewhere else i mean that's
what the they're not they're not going
to want to see him go hoist a trophy
elsewhere
so i'm sure there's that double whammy
yet you don't want to play with the
quarterback who's angry
who's not going to want to be out there
do you believe that he has taken his
last snap
in houston you know susie i've thought
about this a lot and i've
you know i i come down on on two
factoids
that desean watson has never had to make
a decision like
this in his life and stand there and get
a lot of
disdain thrown his way because
everybody's on his side now but at some
point i think
that some of the uh feeling is probably
going to go against him he's been
he's a he's a boy scout he's a he's a
he's a perfect guy he's been a
great player and a great houston texan
uh he was great at clemson in the
community everything he's a
he's a wonderful human being but on the
other hand
nick casario takes this job after being
in new england for two decades
and the thing we don't know about nick
casario he has watched
bill belichick make every decision
for you know through the patriots
dynasty winning six super bowls
but he himself has never had to make
a big decision never so i don't know how
i don't know how desean watson's going
to handle it
i don't know how nick casario's going to
handle it they're both playing
uh hardball for now and we'll see but
you know honestly susie one of the one
one of the sean watson's friend somebody
who's close to him
told me this week that the money is not
gonna mean anything to desean
that if he says he's not playing for the
texans he said i
i think you can take it to the bank so i
my guess is and i would assume this
happens before the draft but maybe it
doesn't
uh that the texans will trade them but
again
it is a wild guess and that's all i can
do right now
because nobody knows uh deep
in inside of each person's heart deshaun
watson and nick casario
uh and and also the owner of the texans
cal mcnair
you know how far they are willing to go
uh
until they step over that line and uh
and either trade them or basically say
we're going to make them sit for the
year
and deshaun watson met with this new
coach last week and reiterated he is not
planning on playing what's the latest
with jj watt
you know i saw this morning um i forget
i think john clayton reported it that uh
that he's he's down to
green bay tennessee or buffalo all of
which
seem to be very logical candidates
um and i think if it comes down to money
he probably won't take green bay
but i think if it comes down to his
heart he would
take green bay i just don't know right
now how seriously green bay is taking
this
i know that uh i i interviewed him a
couple years ago when houston
was practicing in green bay and i'm
telling you this is
totally bizarre for a three-time
defensive player of the year in the nfl
jj watt was star struck practicing
on the same grounds that he had
watched his green bay packer heroes
practice
when he used to come up and watch
training camp when he was when he was a
boy growing up
outside of milwaukee i love that story
because it it's so
rare that a player actually acts human
when it comes to that kind of thing that
he would actually take the time
i mean it shows that other side about
that day what i'll never forget
is that he got this and it's online you
can see it if you just google i don't
know
peter king jj watt green bay you'd
probably find on youtube
this uh nbc sport or maybe it's on
nbcsports.com
this video i did with him but it just he
gets this far away look in his eyes like
this is one of the coolest days i've
ever had
in sports and this was an august
practice on the fields across the street
from lambeau field
in green bay and people who've been
there know it's
outside the don hudson uh practice
center that that green bay practice is
in
and they have their training camp on
these outdoor fields and
j.j watt was just thrilled to be there
so you could see him riding a bike next
year you can see him picking up a kid's
bike and riding
i could definitely i could definitely
see it do you realize he did ride a bike
that day and broke the seat and he felt
so bad for the kid
that he then mowed the kids mother the
money
to replace the bike all right peter we
have a theme going on because yesterday
when michael irvin was on
he basically confessed to stealing i
don't know how many bikes
when he was a kid right in in a lot of
bikes
so we have the theme now of michael
irvin stealing bikes and tj watt
breaking bikes
i i think we should maybe start
discussing cycling next i'm starting to
think that we have a theme going on here
because you know listen maybe maybe
maybe after after his football career
he'll do uh
he'll do a tour de france spin or
something like that
can you imagine how how ridiculous tj
would look
i mean you know riding a bike or a in a
tour de france thing
i i think it makes i don't know if i
want to vision ridiculous they'd have to
get a pretty big bike
that's that's like the jaws though right
they'd have to build a really big boat
uh peter can you introduce us to chuck
the dog please because when i sit in the
seat i get to talk about what i want to
talk about it's usually dogs
so we came up with this for chuck um we
gave him a little bit of a of a stat
look
retriever lab mix acquired from a
maryland shelter in 2017. tell us about
chuck the dog
well chuck is sitting here right now
he's uh he's waiting
uh i'm gonna have a chicken sausage here
for lunch in brooklyn
and chuck is very excited usually he'd
be watching me
as i would do a talk show but today uh
because the sausage is being made
uh he cannot be bothered but he's a good
dog who barks too much
but uh he likes apartment living in new
york
that's all we care about any shelter dog
will like apartment living it's much
better than sheltered
peter thank you so much for coming on i
do appreciate it
suzy you're 10 times better than your
husband
oh can you just do me a favor and put
that on a t-shirt please
you could possibly is that a drop jason
can we can we save that forever
definitely peter i hope you'll come on
next time i'm back in the chair next
time i lock rich in the basement
happy to do it thank you so much that's
the great peter king
hey you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here